انضم الينا من فريسه الشاعر ودبلوماسيه
العراقي شوقي عبد الامير اهلا بك سيد شوقي
ونبارك لك هذا الفوز بهذه الجائزه ونريد
ان تعبر بلغتك الادبيه عن شعورك بهذه
الجائزه
او هذا الوسام
مساء الخير شكرا لكم شكرا لكم يعني هذه
لحظه كبيره وهي اول اطلاله لي بعد استلام
الجائزه والتكريم عبر قناتكم الكريمه
فماذا اقول اقول كما كانت المقدمه جميله
التي تفضلتم بها هي
تتويج لمسيره
ربطت الشرق بالغرب انا يا سيدتي منذ
اربعين عاما في هذا الجسر الذي يمضي
باتجاهين بين ثقافه العربيه والثقافه
الفرنسيه بحثا ودراسه
وترجمه وشعرا هذه اليوم يعني اعتراف جميل
وكبير ليس لي شخصيا لاهميه هذا التواصل
لاهميه هذا الحضن الثقافي هذه التفاته عبر
شخصي لكنها تقول
للمهتمين بهذا الوسط انها الساعه يجب ان
نعمل في الثقافه سيد شوقي سيد شوقي يعني
هي عباره بسيطه لكنها تختزن الكثير من
المعاني ربط الشرق بالغرب ماذا تقصد بهذه
الكلمه وانت على اساس هذا الامر يعني هذا
كان عنصر اساسي
لمنحك هذا الوسام لكن عمليا على ارض
الواقع كيف حصل هذا الربط الثقافي بين
الشرق والغرب من خلال انتاجك
جميل سؤال مهم
سيدي
الشرق والغرب يتواصل شئنا ام ابينا بكل
انواع الجسور الاقتصاديه والسياحيه
والدبلوماسيه والسياسيه والحربيه كل
اشكالها لكن هناك
جسر عميق لا يرى دائما ولا يحتل الساحات
كثير اللي هو جسر الثقافه الابداع نحن في
كل الميادين الاخرى التي ذكرتها مستهلكون
فقط الا في الابداع نحن انداد في الابداع
نملك الشعر كما يملكون الشعر نملك الروايه
كما يملكون الروايه نملك الفكر الفنون
السينما الموسيقى كما يملكون في كل ميادين
الابداع نستطيع ان نكون انداد للغرب لكننا
في الميادين الاخرى مستهلكون فقط اي ندفع
ونصمت يجب ان ننتبه الى هذا الفارق وان
صوره العرب اليوم في اوروبا بحاجه الى عمل
ثقافي عميق ليس فقط بحاجه الى عمل
دبلوماسي ولا الى عمل سياسي وتجاري كلها
مهمه
ولكن من الاخر سيده هو الدور الثقافي
ايهما استفاد من الاخره الجانب الادبي في
شخصيتك ام الدبلوماسي هل استفدت من مهنتك
كدبلوماسي في
هذا الجسر الثقفي بين الغرب والشرق ام ان
مخزونك الادبي هو الذي ساعد في اختراق
مجالات دبلوماسيه عندنا
كلاهما كلاهما في الواقع لا يمكن الغاء
الواحد بالاخر من الصعب ان نفرق وجودي في
فرنسا تعلم اللغه الفرنسيه علاقتي مع
الادباء الفرنساويين اصدقائي كبار الادباء
ان التقيت بكت ورامبو واراغون وكيفيك ونوى
يعني الاسماء الكبيره وانا عضو في اهم
مجله شعريه اليوم اسمها بويزي عضو في هيئه
التحرير من 20 سنه هذا كله مهم خدمني ولكن
خدمني ايضا علاقتي باللغه العربيه علاقتي
بالادب والثقافه والتراث والماضي الماضي
الثقافي المنطقه يعني اور
ويعني
مصر القديمه
وفينيقيا انا حتى في شعري كما رايت الان
اينانه او كذا انا في شعري لا يوجد ماضي
ولا يوجد حاضر ولا يوجد مستقبل يوجد زمن
فقط الزمن كل واحد يعني ابطال الماضي
الاسطوريين موجودين كانهم احياء
لا اتعامل
مثل ما يتعامل السياسي او الاقتصادي مع
الحاضره اتعامل مع زمن العمودي الدائري
الذي يجمع كل الزمن كل قامش بالنسبه لي
وايمانه يعيشون اليوم
لاننا في اللغه وفي الشعر نستطيع ان نخترق
الازمنه هذه مساله مهمه بمن تاثرت اضعها
في باريس انا
عفوا عذرا عذرا للمقاطعه هنا لكن يعني كما
هو معروف انا كانت لك علاقه مع مظفر
النواب
كان
اشرت الى
اشرت الى يعني الدول ربما اثرت فيك او
يعني ساهمت في هذا المخزون
الثقافي الذي ترجم ابداعا شعريا وثقافيا
من خلالك بمن تاثرت في العالم العربي قبل
ان تنتقل لتصبح جسرا مع الغرب
تاثري في العالم العربي جاء عبر مراحل
اولا كان الشعر الجاهلي قبل الاسلام انا
ارفض تسميه الجاهلي لانه شعر عظيم شعر قبل
الاسلام المعلقات امرئ القيس طرف ابن
العابد هذه كانوا معلمي الكبار
بعدها جاء الشعر العباسي المتنبي وابو
نواس
وبعدها انتقلنا في العصر الحديث الى اعلام
الشعر الحديث
ادونيس السياب يعني
هؤلاء اللي هم يعني شعراء اللي اثروا فيا
في
من اجانب العربي لكن من الجانب الفرنسي
انا يعني يعني
احببت بعمق وترجمت رامبو ارسل رامبو
والشاعر الكبير
واشاعر ايضا هؤلاء اهم شاعرين بالنسبه الي
بفرنسا يعني اعتقد انني تاثرت بهم لا اعرف
ذلك بالضبط لكن ذولا واكبتهم وكانت لي
علاقه صداقه عميقه مع جيوبك طيب
عندما يطلب من الاديب او الشاعر ان يختار
عملا فهو يرفض كونه يشعر بان كل اعماله هي
كابنائه ولكن
سلاف ما تحب من اعمالك من ابيات شعريه
نختم بهذا اللقاء وتهديها لكل من يتابع
ويحب انتاجك الادبي
والله انا ساقرا بهذه الحاله من الذاكره
من الذاكره قصيده يعني سريعه اللي هي
عنوانها كتابه
كتبت الى غيمه ماءها
للطريق وقد بعدت قريه
للبلاد التي احرقت فيك جذرا ودرارا
كتبت لوجه رياحا لاغنيه حجرا للرماد
انتظارا كتبت لي لافته صمتها المستعارا
كتبت السماء انحدارا كتبت على جسد جسدا
على جدف غابه على كل طير نهارا كتبت لكم
ان بابي موصده فاهدموني جدارا كتبت مسارا
ومحوت مسارى
كتبت على كتبت كتبت ولم اورق اليوم الا
انكسارا
ولكنني قد كتبت مرارا لاحيا مرارا
جميل جميل جميل جميل جدا جدا جدا
شكرا جزيلا لك
الشاعر العراقي ودبلوماسي شوقي عبد الامير
كنا نتمنى لو يكون الوقت اطول ونسمع اكثر
من شعرك طبعا شكرا جزيلا لك فنقولها لك
فلتحيا مرارا هذه ليست هذه
لنحيا معا المراره هذه هي الرساله الادب
يمنحون حياه جديده
لنحيا مرارا شكرا لك